This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You've seen a logo that Tom Geismar has designed. You probably saw one today. Xerox, mobile oil, NYU, PBS, Univision. The Boston Public Transit Systems Mark is a T in a circle. Tom Geismar did that. But his work in that of his long time business partner Ivan Tremayev, who passed away in late 2017, is truly fused into the DNA of most modern logos you see today, whether they design them or not. In 1961, the logo for Chase Bank that he designed, the blue octagon with the square in the middle, was introduced. It's still used everywhere, and it's considered one of the first of its kind in the US,
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。你一定见过汤姆·盖斯马设计的标志。你今天可能就见过一个。施乐、美孚石油、纽约大学、公共电视网、环球电视网。波士顿公共交通系统的标志是一个圆圈里套着一个字母T。汤姆·盖斯马设计的。但是他和他的长期商业伙伴伊万·切尔迈耶（于2017年底去世）的工作，真正融入了你今天看到的绝大多数现代标志的基因中，无论这些标志是否由他们设计。1961年，他为大通银行设计的标志——中间带方块的蓝色八边形——问世了。它至今仍在到处使用，并被认为是美国同类设计中的首创之一，
an abstract dynamic shape representing a giant company. The logo was a real sea change for Chase. Well, Chase at that time was really Chase Manhattan Bank because it was the merger of two giant banks, Chase National Bank and the Bank of the Manhattan Company. They had a logo which featured a map of the United States, a globe of the world, the wording, Chase Manhattan Bank, and a few other things. It was quite a mix.
一个代表巨型公司的抽象动态形状。这个标志对大通银行来说是一个真正的巨变。嗯，当时的大通实际上是大通曼哈顿银行，因为它是两家巨型银行合并而成的，即大通国民银行和曼哈顿公司银行。它们的标志曾以美国地图、世界地球仪、文字“大通曼哈顿银行”以及其他一些元素为特色。那真是一个大杂烩。
They were in the process of building the first modern skyscraper in the Wall Street area because a lot of the financial firms were moving up to Midtown at that point. David Rockefeller was in charge of that process, though he was only third in command at the time at the bank. And he felt that it would be appropriate to have also a modern contemporary looking mark for this newly formed, basically, a merger of these two banks. And we discussed with him the idea of maybe we could just do something abstract because no one had any idea of a symbol of banking, of a dollar sign.
他们当时正在华尔街地区建造第一座现代摩天大楼，因为当时许多金融公司都在向中城迁移。戴维·洛克菲勒负责这个过程，尽管他在当时的银行里只排在第三位。他觉得为这个新成立的、基本上是两家银行合并的机构设计一个现代且具有当代感的标志会很合适。我们和他讨论了或许可以做一个抽象设计的主意，因为当时没有人对银行的符号或美元符号有什么概念。
And Chase was so big, I mean, they were going to be either the number one or number two, and I remember largest bank in the country. They had advertising in the newspapers every day, certainly around the New York metropolitan area, you couldn't miss their branches. They were everywhere. So the idea that you could establish something So the idea that you could establish something relatively abstract as their mark, much as the Red Cross or Mercedes, Chevrolet, I mean, there are some around, there were some at the time, but not many at all. And that was the idea, anyhow, that we could do that, establish something that was bold, and that would be recognized as representing the bank.
而且大通太大了，我的意思是，它们当时要么是全国第一大，要么是第二大银行，我记得是全国最大的银行。他们每天都在报纸上做广告，特别是在纽约大都会区，你绝不会错过他们的分行。它们无处不在。因此，你可以建立一个相对抽象的概念作为他们的标志，就像红十字会、梅赛德斯、雪佛兰一样——我的意思是，当时确实有一些，虽然不是很多。无论如何，这就是当时的设想：我们可以做到这一点，建立一个醒目的、能够被认为代表这家银行的标志。
Right. And so how did you come up with this shape? What were the drawings like? established something that was bold and that would be recognized as representing the bank. Right. And so how did you come up with this shape like what were the drawings like? What were you thinking when that shape was applied to Chase? Well, we wanted something bold, something that would stand out, something that could be reproduced in various materials, something that could work at a small size. And at the time, it was very important also that something that could work in black and white in the newspaper, there was no color printing
没错。那么，你是怎么想出这个形状的呢？当时的草图是什么样的？建立一个醒目的、能够被认为代表这家银行的标志。没错。那么，你是怎么想出这个形状的？当时的草图是什么样的？当这个形状应用到大通银行时，你在想什么？嗯，我们想要一个醒目的、能脱颖而出的、可以用各种材料复制的、在小尺寸下也能使用的标志。在当时，也非常重要的一点是它必须能在报纸上以黑白印刷呈现，因为那时没有彩色印刷
in newspapers at that time. Something that could work on television, but also on a letterhead or a formal announcement. So we tried to keep all those things in mind. And we looked at a number of different designs. This particular one is also quite similar to old Chinese coins. They were rectangular, they had a hole in the middle, and so on. And that was helpful in terms of rationalizing why that particular design. And so Rockefeller was on your side in this, but did they expect something quite so
报纸上没有彩色印刷。它必须能在电视上使用，也能用在信头或正式公告上。所以我们试图把所有这些都记在心里。我们看了很多不同的设计。这个特定的设计其实也非常类似于中国古代的钱币。它们是长方形的，中间有个孔，诸如此类。这在合理解释为什么选择这种特定设计时很有帮助。所以洛克菲勒在这方面是支持你们的，但他们是否期待过如此
dynamic and radical and revolutionary, or were they expecting something more akin to the map of the United States and the globe and the world banking word on top? I mean, what were they expecting? Well, you say David Rockefeller certainly went along with this idea, but the two people above him, John McCloy, the chairman, and George Champion, the president, were pretty shocked when we showed it to them. Champion said, well, why can't we just have a picture of the building? Or the sculpture we're going to have out front. And we tried to persuade them that was a bad idea. And then McClaude eventually said, David, we've given you this project. If you want
充满活力、激进而革命性的设计，或者他们期待的是更接近美国地图、地球仪和世界银行字样的设计？我的意思是，他们当时期待的是什么？嗯，正如你所说，戴维·洛克菲勒确实同意这个想法，但他上面的两个人——董事长约翰·麦克洛伊和总裁乔治·尚皮恩——当我们把设计展示给他们时，都大吃一惊。尚皮恩说，嗯，为什么我们不直接放一张建筑物的照片呢？或者放一张我们打算摆在前门外的雕塑的照片。我们试图说服他们这是一个糟糕的主意。然后麦克洛伊最终说：“戴维，我们把这个项目交给你了。如果你想要
this for the retail bank, you can do it. But I don't want to see it on my letterhead. I don't want to see it in my office. I don't want to see it. I really don't understand it and don't like it. Soon thereafter they adopted it and the bank went ahead and did it and it was only I think six months later that we were down there and ran into McCloy in the hallway and there he was with a tie with the symbol on it with cufflinks with symbol on it, with a pin in his lapel with a symbol on it. So it was a great lesson to us because suddenly, someone who couldn't understand it
这个标志用在零售银行上，你可以去做。但我不想在我的信头上看到它。我不想在我的办公室里看到它。我不想看到它。我真的不理解它，也不喜欢它。”不久之后，他们还是采用了它，银行也推进了这个项目。我想仅仅过了六个月，我们在那儿办事时在走廊里遇到了麦克洛伊，他当时就系着印有这个标志的领带，戴着印有这个标志袖扣，翻领上还别着印有这个标志的别针。所以这给我们上了一课，因为突然之间，一个原本无法理解它
as an abstract design now really accepted it greatly as a representation of his company. So you mentioned the lessons of McCleley, you know, fully on board with the mark as soon as it became the mark of his bank. Could you expand on what some of those lessons are and how you use them to think about your work today and how you deal with clients? Well, I think the big lesson that we learned then was that what people react to is not the mark, but they react to is the institution that it represents. So if you ask people, you know, what do they think are good marks?
作为一个抽象设计的标志的人，现在真的非常接受它作为自己公司象征的意义。所以你提到了麦克洛伊的教训，你知道的，他一旦让这个标志成为他银行的标志，就完全支持了。你能详细说说这些教训是什么，以及你如何用它们来思考你今天的工作和与客户的交往吗？嗯，我认为我们当时学到的最重要的一课是，人们对标志本身没有反应，他们有反应的是它所代表的机构。所以如果你问人们，你知道，他们认为什么是好标志？
They will almost inevitably mention companies or institutions or whatever that they think highly of. So they'll often say Apple and they'll say Nike and others that they think highly of. So they'll often say Apple and they'll say Nike and others that they think highly of. The alumus never say Enron, for example. Even though Enron had a very good mark designed by a famous designer, Paul Ren, so it has nothing to do with the quality pretty much, it has to do with what it represents. Right. So the Chase logo was something that's from the ground up, just a brand new invention. But you've also done a number of adaptations and updates. And I was wondering if you could talk about the PBS logo, which is something that I think
他们几乎不可避免地会提到他们高度评价的公司、机构或其他什么。所以他们经常会说苹果，他们会说耐克以及其他他们高度评价的对象。所以他们经常会说苹果，他们会说耐克以及其他他们高度评价的对象。他们绝不会说安然，例如。尽管安然有一个由著名设计大师保罗·兰德设计的非常好的标志，所以这几乎与质量无关，而与它所代表的东西有关。对。所以大通的标志是从头开始的，完全是一个崭新的发明。但你们也做过许多改编和更新。我想知道你能不能谈谈PBS（公共广播电视公司）的标志，我觉得很多人对这个标志都很熟悉，
a lot of people are familiar with, what that process was like and what you were trying to do there. Yeah, very often we will try and build on something that's there if it has real value. In the case of PBS, there was a problem that they and the stations, the various public broadcasting stations had. At the time, people presumed it was the public broadcasting system, the way CBS is, the Columbia broadcasting system, the way CBS is the Columbia broadcasting system and so on. At CBS, they have a number of own stations and whatever. And the issue was that actually the stations had complete responsibility for raising their own funds to keep in business.
很多人都很熟悉这个过程是怎样的，你们当时试图在其中实现什么。是的，非常经常地，如果现有的东西有真正的价值，我们会尝试在它的基础上进行构建。就PBS而言，他们和各家公共广播电视台面临着一个问题。当时，人们以为它是公共广播系统，就像CBS（哥伦比亚广播公司）那样，CBS是哥伦比亚广播公司，诸如此类。在CBS，他们拥有许多自己的电视台之类的。而问题在于，实际上各电视台需要完全自行负责筹集资金来维持运营。
And PBS is not a conglomerate that supplies funding and so on. It provides some programming, but not funding. People misperceived what PBS was and their logo was a very clever PBS where the P was a person sort of a silhouette of a man. And the idea was, could we do something that makes it clearer that it's public television, not some kind of network? So our thought was actually at the time to take that P that they had out of the PBS, turned around, sort of gave them a lobotomy and fixed them up a bit and then repeated it so that it was the idea of multiple people, that it was public TV. But that was the whole reason to do it, but again it got built on something that existed a part of the letter, so it
PBS并不是一个提供资金等支持的企业集团。它提供一些节目，但不提供资金。人们对PBS是什么产生了误解，而他们当时的标志是一个非常聪明的PBS，其中字母P是一个人的剪影，有点像一个男人的轮廓。当时的设想是：我们能不能做点什么，让人更清楚地知道这是一个公共电视台，而不是某种商业电视网？所以当时我们的想法是，把他们PBS里的那个P拿出来，把它转个方向，有点像给它做个脑白金手术然后稍微修正一下，接着把它复制重复，传达出“多个人”的概念，即这是公共电视。这就是当时这样做的全部原因，但同样地，它是建立在原有字母的一部分的基础上的，所以
was no great radical change at the time, but it was something more appropriate and something to solve a problem. So how do you steer a client to select the shape and the idea that in your heart you really know is the right one. How many options do you give them? How many variations do you present? Is there a psychology in presenting a logo to a group like this. Well, today we do often present options. We almost always do, because there is not necessarily one right answer for these issues. You're having to make a decision and go ahead with it. But we explain what the pluses and minuses are
当时并没有什么激进的改变，但它更合适，也解决了一个问题。那么，你如何引导客户选择那个在你心底真正知道是正确形状和构思的方案呢？你给他们多少个选项？你展示多少种变体？向这样一个群体展示一个标志时，其中有什么心理学技巧吗？嗯，今天我们确实经常展示选项。我们几乎总是这样做，因为对于这些问题，未必只有一个正确的答案。你必须做出决定并将其推行下去。但我们会解释各种选项的优缺点，
of the various options. And we often have a favorite, which we try you know, explain what the pluses and minuses are of the various options. And we often have a favorite, which we try to push, if we can. But there's not necessarily, you know, the obvious right answer. And when you have a favorite, do you plainly state that it's your favorite or do you just present it first or present it last? Is there a gavesmanship in this at all? There may be a little bit, but not that much. And we don't usually state which one we favor if we're showing options, but we encourage them to ask us later.
各种选项的优缺点。而且我们通常会有最偏爱的一个，如果我们能做到的话，我们会试着去推销它。但并不一定存在那个显而易见的正确答案。当你有一个最喜欢的选项时，你是会明说这是你最喜欢的，还是只是把它排在第一个或最后一个展示？这里面有什么博弈的技巧吗？可能有一点点，但没那么多。如果我们展示选项，通常不会明确说明我们偏爱哪一个，但我们会鼓励他们稍后向我们询问。
And we try to also get there, take on it. And one of the first things we say, actually, when we're before we present anything, is it's never love at first sight. So the thing is, if you can imagine what it might be like in actual use, and that's what we try to show when we're showing designs to be marks, what it might look like in various appropriate kind of uses.
我们也会努力了解他们的看法。实际上，在我们展示任何东西之前，我们说的第一句话就是：这绝不是一见钟情。所以关键在于，如果你能想象它在实际使用中会是什么样子——而这正是我们在展示标志设计时努力去呈现的——它在各种合适的应用场景下会是什么样。
So I see the chase logo on my iPhone. It works really well as an app icon. Is that a coincidence? Is there something that has made it indoor over 50 years and works on a tiny screen as well as a print ad and as a tie-tack and everything? Well, it is a coincidence, but it happens to have worked very much in our favor, because we've always tried to do things that are very clear, very simple, and that can be reduced to a small size. So suddenly today, it's a requirement, really, of almost every mark that has any kind of social exposure, and it does work well. And it just happens, I think.
所以我看到我的iPhone上有大通银行的标志。它作为应用图标效果非常好。这是一种巧合吗？有什么东西让它经历了50多年依然历久弥新，在微小的屏幕上、在印刷广告中、在领带夹上以及在所有地方都能完美适用？嗯，这确实是一种巧合，但它非常符合我们的利益，因为我们一直努力做那些非常清晰、非常简单、能够缩小到很小尺寸的设计。所以今天突然之间，这几乎成了任何具有社会曝光度的标志的基本要求，而且它的确效果很好。我想这纯粹是个巧合。
Maybe our approach was the right approach that we were lucky that it's certainly applicable today. And in fact, a lot of work we get today is because people have marks that can't work as an app. So has the approach for creating marks changed over 60 years? And because of this, or there are other things that are more fundamental So has the approach for creating marks changed over 60 years? And because of this or there are other things that are more fundamental
也许我们的方法是正确的方法，我们很幸运，它在今天依然适用。事实上，我们今天接到的大量工作都是因为人们的标志无法当作应用图标使用。那么，60年来，创建标志的方法发生变化了吗？是因为这个原因，还是有其他更根本的东西改变了你们的工作？
and the change in the work that you guys do? You know, it actually hasn't changed that much. At least our approach to it hasn't changed that much. Because as I mentioned, we try to really get down to the basic thing, a basic mark that can identify whatever the institution is that we're identifying in a clear way. And we have three criteria, really, which are the basic criteria. One is that it'd be appropriate. You would do something for a sports team that would be quite different for something you
你知道，它其实没有太大改变。至少我们对待它的方法没有太大改变。正如我所提到的，我们努力深入到最核心的东西，一个能够以清晰的方式识别我们所代表的任何机构的基本标志。我们实际上有三个标准，它们是基本标准。第一是合适。你为一个运动队做的设计，和为你为银行做设计，会有很大不同。它要适合客户以及他们的业务。第二个标准是独特，你能看到它、记住它、认出它，也许在见过几次后就能快速认出它，它能脱颖而出并被识别。然后第三个标准是它在各种尺寸、不同材料等情况下都能适用（如果合适的话，而且通常都是）。所以如果它能满足这三个标准，那我们就做得相当不错。
do for a bank, for example. It'd be appropriate to the client and to what they do. The second one would be that it'd be distinctive, that you can see it, you can remember it, you can recognize it, maybe you can do it quickly after having seen it a couple of times, that it will stand out and be recognized. And then the third thing is just that it works in all kinds of sizes, different materials and so on, if that's appropriate and it often is. So if it can meet those three criteria, then we're doing pretty well. How do you balance the concept of being appropriate towards a certain institution and it being
你如何在“适合某个特定机构”的概念与“足够抽象、成为一个人们可以注入意义的空容器”之间取得平衡？嗯，它根本不需要是一个空容器。它也不一定非要是抽象的。对于银行业，我们想不出有什么东西能恰当地代表银行业，但这绝不意味着所有情况都如此。我的意思是，如果有某种真实且合适的东西，你就会努力围绕它进行设计并使其易于理解。这会让人们更容易理解。另一件事是，自从我们做了大通银行的标志后，世界各地的银行，实际上是世界各地的人们都开始制作抽象的标志，但这并不一定合理，因为
abstract enough to be this empty vessel that people poor meaning into? Well, it doesn't have to be an empty vessel at all. It doesn't have to be abstract. For banking, we couldn't think of anything that properly represents banking, but that's not always the case by any means. I mean, if there is something real that's appropriate, then you try to work on that and make it understandable. That's a lot easier for people to understand. The other thing is that once we did the Chase bank, Mark, then banks all over, in fact people all over started using making abstract marks, but it didn't necessarily make sense because
它们没有像大通那样高的曝光度。这种设计只有在你有足够的曝光度、让人们开始认识它时，才会真正发挥作用。对。对。哦，这说得通。比如，我知道你们团队负责设计了很多水族馆的标志。那些标志有很好的形状，在某些方面是抽象的。但它们通常有波浪、鱼以及你能认出代表水族馆的东西。是的，事实上，所有这些水族馆在建筑概念、展览等方面都有不同的侧重点。所以我们甚至试图去体现这一点。显然，鱼和水是所有这些设计中的核心部分，但有些侧重于海洋，有些侧重于淡水，诸如此类。你能谈谈在与客户合作的最开始阶段，你是如何决定是做一个使用公司名称的字标，还是更抽象、更具画意的标志的吗？你如何做出这种决定？
they didn't have anything like the exposure that Chase had. That kind of thing only works really well if you have enough exposure that people come to recognize it. Right. Right. Oh, that makes sense. Like, for example, I know that your group is responsible for a lot of aquarium logos. And those are, you know, they have nice shapes to them and they're abstracted in certain ways. But they often have waves and fish and things that you recognize as the things that it represents as an aquarium. Yes, and actually all those aquariums, they all have different emphasis in terms of the concept of the building and the exhibits and so on. And so we're even trying to represent that. Obviously fish and water are the key part of all of them, but some are about the oceans and some are about fresh water and so on. Can you talk about how you decide when you are in the very beginning stages of working with a client, whether or not you're going to do some kind of wordmark that uses the company's name or something more abstract or pictorial, how do you make that type of decision?
嗯，这始终是一个关键决定。通常我们不会单方面做出决定。例如，我们会同时展示这两种选项，以及这两者的优缺点。很大程度上，这当然取决于最初的公司名称是什么。但总的来说，如果名称很短——短的意思可能是五个字母左右——并且很有特色，那么我们就会从让这个字标具有独特性的想法开始。我们最近为很多科技公司做了大量工作。而且，你知道的，他们所做的事情很难理解，要在任何有意义的层面上表现出来也肯定
Well, that's always a key decision. And often we don't necessarily make the decision. We might show both options, for example, and what the pluses and minuses are of those two things. And a lot of that depends of course on what the name is to begin with. But generally, if the name is short and by short, I mean maybe five letters or something, and is distinctive, then we would start with the idea of making that word distinctive. We've been doing a lot of work for a lot of technology companies recently. And, you know, what they're doing is pretty hard to understand and certainly
非常困难。你知道，这不像他们是在收割苹果什么的，你就可以画一个苹果之类的东西。要找到一个合适、有意义且具有独特性标志是极其困难的。那么，当有人描述、当一家公司描述他们所做的事情时，有没有什么特定的线索是你们开始为他们设计标志的关键切入点？还是说每次都完全不同？
very hard to represent in any meaningful way. You know, it's not as if they're harvesting apples or something and you can do an apple or whatever. It's extremely difficult to find something that's appropriate, meaningful, but also distinctive. And so is there a certain thing that you listen for when somebody describes, when a company describes what they do that is a key into your process of beginning to design something for them or is it just different every time?
嗯，我们会经历一个完整的流程来开始为他们设计，还是每次都完全不同？嗯，我们会经历一个完整的流程，试图采访很多人，真正去了解他们的文化和业务，当然还有了解竞争对手，了解他们与谁并肩或在与谁竞争，从而对当前的情况有相当深入的了解。在这个过程中，通过采访人们，往往会在一些有趣的地方产生灵感，
Well, we go through a whole process of beginning to design something for them, or is it just different every time? Well, we go through a whole process of trying to interview a lot of people, really trying to understand the culture and what they do, obviously, and to understand the competition, and who they're seen with or against, and really to get a pretty in-depth understanding of what the situation is. And in the process of doing all that and interviewing people, often ideas, funny places,
可能会冒出一个，比如对话中的一句俏皮话什么的，但这正是很多创意的来源。所以，在1961年，你可以推出一个八边形，让它变得非常简单、醒目，并与大通银行联系在一起，因为大通太大了。现在，八边形已经被用烂了。你不能再把一个八边形当作一家公司的抽象标志推出来了。是因为形状太多了，还是因为世界上有限制，今天要想出一个简单的醒目图形是不是更难了？
come up, might be just a wise crack in a conversation or something, but that's where a lot of the ideas come from. So, in 1961, you can introduce an octagon and have it be pretty simple, be bold, and be associated with Chase because Chase is so big. Now, the octagon, it's closed off. You can't put an octagon out there as an abstract mark for a company. Is it harder to have a bold graphic that's simple today, just because of the number of shapes or just limited in the world?
嗯，确实很难。是的，有太多了。现在有了各种小图标、表情符号以及乱七八糟的东西，周围实在有太多图形了。所以是的，这很困难。我们现在做的是，在向客户展示任何东西之前，我们都会进行初步的法律检索。所以我们尽量不向客户展示任何连他们所谓的“初筛检索”都还没通过的设计，因为我们不想让他们爱上一个设计，
Well, it is hard. Yes, there are so many. And now with little icons and emojis and whatever, there's just so much around. So yes, it is difficult. What we do now is before we show anything to our clients, we have done a preliminary legal search. So we try not to show anything to a client that hasn't at least passed the initial, what they call a knockout search, because we don't want them to fall in
然后发现他们根本无法使用。你有没有曾经爱上过某个设计，却发现无法使用？哦，当然有。我们只是不把它拿出来展示。不，我是说，这种情况非常多。其中一个复杂之处在于，当然，很多东西在特定的业务领域内被注册为商标。例如，我举的一个例子是红星。很显然，它代表中国，但它也是梅西百货的标志，是圣培露的标志，是喜力的标志。它是许多不同东西的标志，而且它们都是合法使用的。它们都有权使用它，而我们又是另一个。所以，事情并没有
love with something and then find out, you know, if they can't use it. Have you ever fallen in love with something and found out you couldn't use it? Oh, sure. We just don't show it. No, I mean, very much. And one of the one of the complications is of course things are registered as marks with the end of a certain area of business. For example, I'm one example we give is the red star. So obviously, represents China, but it's also Macy's. It's San Pellegrino, it's Heineken. It's many different things, and they're all doing it legally. They will have the right to use it, and we're another. So, it's not
那么简单。所以，你可能会设计出某个东西，也许它类似于完全不同领域的某个东西，你必须特别注册这个标志，无论你处于什么业务领域。因此，这就面临一个决定：你是假设没问题而继续推进，因为在完全不同的世界里不会引起混淆，还是放弃。是的。
quite so simple. So, you might have something, you come up with it, maybe similar to something in a very different field, and you have to register the mark in particular, you know, whatever area of business you're in. And so, then there's that decision, you know, do you go ahead presuming it's going to be okay, because there's not going to be confusion, because you're in a completely different world, or not. Yeah.
向公众推出新标志的方法，在你们工作的这段时间里真的改变了吗？你们现在是如何处理这个问题的？你们如何看待在网上推出标志并引发各种反应的这种“血腥运动”？嗯，我们通常的建议是：什么都别说，直接做就是了。嗯，我认为如果更广泛地来看，人们现在的视觉意识要强得多。人们现在的视觉意识要强得多。每个人都在看手机，他们在看图标，
Has this method of introducing things to the public, that's really changed in the time period when you've been working? How do you approach that now? And what do you think of the sort of blood sport of introducing logos and reactions online? And that kind of thing? Well, our usual recommendation is don't say a word, just do it. Well, I think if you look at more broadly, I think people are much more visually aware today. are much more visually aware today. Everyone's looking at their phone, they're looking at icons,
他们在看应用，他们在看所有这些东西。所以它更多地成为了文化的一部分。因此，想要做出好东西的愿望——从我们的角度来看，这绝对是一件积极的事情——正是其中的一部分。扮演评论家是另一部分。但我认为总的来说，人们对这些事情有更高的觉悟、意识和批判精神，这是一件很棒的事。
they're looking at apps, they're looking at all these things. And so it's much more a part of the culture. So I think the desire to do something good, which from our point of view, is certainly a positive thing, is part of that. The idea of being a critic is another part of it. But I think overall, it's great that people are much more conscious and aware and critical of these things.
汤姆·盖斯马是切尔迈耶、盖斯马及哈维夫设计事务所的联合创始人。正如我在节目开始时提到的那样，汤姆的长期搭档伊万·切尔迈耶于2017年12月去世。他们一起工作了60年。这次采访的扩展文字版将收录在一本关于该事务所的新书中，
Tom Geismar is the co-founder of Tremayev and Geismar and Haviv. As I mentioned at the beginning of the show, Tom's longtime partner Ivan Tremayev died in December of 2017. They worked together for 60 years. An expanded text version of this interview will be included in a new book about the firm
该书将于2018年5月由标准手册出版社出版。我们将在节目页面上提供链接。接下来，是来自《罪犯》制作团队的全新广播乌托邦（Radiotopia）节目的超长预览。《罪犯》顺便说一下，根据他们对我的要求，这是我个人的最爱播客，我怎么夸奖它都不为过，稍后马上为您播出他们全新系列的短篇故事和预览。现在为您播放广播乌托邦（Radiotopia）新节目的预览，制作者来自《罪犯》。一般来说，它们产卵大约50到100个，这些卵被产在一个白色的丝质
that will be published by standards manual in May of 2018. We'll have a link on the show page. Coming up, an extended preview of a brand new radio topia show from the producers of Criminal. Criminal, by the way, depending on what they ask me, is my personal favorite podcast I cannot praise it enough, while the short story and preview of their brand new series right after this. And now a preview of a new show in radiotopia from the makers of criminal. Generally speaking, they lay about 50 to 100 eggs and these are laid in a white silk
卵袋中。小蜘蛛孵化后，母蜘蛛几乎立刻就会产下另一批卵。这就是所谓的营养卵。这些是永远不会孵化的卵，它们将作为螺旋翅蜘蛛的食物。这是长岛大学生物学教授、美国自然历史博物馆常驻研究员比尔·肖特博士。他正在向我们介绍黑蕾丝织网蜘蛛。它在美国很常见。你
and sack. And after the baby's hatch, the mother just about immediately lays another set of eggs. And these are what are known as trophic eggs. These are eggs that are never going to hatch, and they will serve as food for the spiral wings. This is Dr. Bill Schott, a professor of biology at Long Island University, and a research associate in residence at the American Museum of Natural History. He's telling us about the black lace weaver spider. It's common in the United States. You've
可能以前见过。你现在家里的某个地方可能就有一只。它们很难描述，因为它们看起来就像普通的蜘蛛。它们大约半英寸大小，呈棕黑色。没有不寻常的斑纹。也没有美丽的蜘蛛网。所以当小蜘蛛孵化时，它们立即开始吃卵，吃它们母亲产下的营养卵。
probably seen one before. You probably have one somewhere in your yard right now. They're hard to describe because they look like a spider. They're about half an inch brownish black in color. No unusual markings. No beautiful webs. So when the spiderlings hatch, they immediately set about eating the eggs, the trophic eggs that their mother has laid.
现在，蜘蛛和许多其他节肢动物——那些有外骨骼的动物，它们的骨骼长在身体外面，比如虾、龙虾、蝎子或昆虫。它们唯一能长大的方法就是脱掉外壳，也就是蜕皮，蜕掉它们的角质层。所以在它们的第一次蜕皮后，它们的食物基本上就吃完了。它们已经吃完了母亲产生的营养卵。就在那时，它们做了一件非常奇怪的事情。母蜘蛛基本上会在网上轻轻振动，把小蜘蛛吸引到她身边。所以就像她在网上敲击一样，小蜘蛛被这种
Now, spiders and a lot of other orthropods, animals that have an outer cover and they have their skeletons on the outside of their bodies like shrimp or lobster or scorpions or insects. It's the only way that they can grow in size is to shed their outer, that's the mold, their, their, their, this cuticle. So after their first mold, they're pretty much out of food. So they've gone through the trophic eggs that their mother has produced. And that's when they do something really kind of strange. The mother basically thrums on the web, drawing the babies to her. So it's like she drums on the web a bit and they are attracted to that vibration of the
网的振动所吸引，成群结队地爬到她身上。蜘蛛对振动非常敏感，所以她基本上在做的就是拨动她的丝，吸引小蜘蛛来找她。这是琳达·雷尔博士。她是康奈尔大学的高级讲师和高级研究员，她的专业是蜘蛛的社会生活。它们对运动做出反应，成群结队地向她移动，并开始进食。显然，它们在一个小时内就把她吃掉了。她是怎么让它们吃掉自己的？它们难道是凭本能知道这一点的吗？它们确实凭本能知道这一点。它们做的是……
web and they swarm all over her. Spiders are all about vibration and so what she basically does is she's plucking on her silk and attracting the youngsters to come to her. This is Dr. Linda Raior. She's a senior lecturer and senior research associate at Cornell and her specialty is the social lives of spiders. They respond to the movements and move in toward her as a group and start feeding. And evidently, they eat her within the hour. How does she get them to eat her? Do they just know this instinctually that they know this instinctually. What they do is...
基本上是注入这种富含酶的……消化液……然后分解她体内的组织。你知道的，这几乎就像它们用吸管把她吸干一样。就像一杯蛋白质奶昔。把她活活吃掉。是的，活活吃掉。然后它们会在一起待上另外三到四周。所以这是一大群小蜘蛛，之后它们会从网上分散开来，成为
is basically inject this enzyme-laden... gut juice... and break down the inside of her body. You know, it's almost like they slurper up through a straw. Like a protein milkshake. Eating her alive. Yeah, eating her alive. And then they will hang out for another three, four weeks together. So there's a mass of these baby spiders and then they'll disperse from the web to become
成年蜘蛛。这简直是自然而然的。我会称之为父母行为。达到了我们认为极端的程度。它们结果都是超级伟大的母亲。诱导幼蛛来到她身边并开始以她为食的行为完全是故意的。她在邀请它们。她请求它们这样做，这就是她为孩子们做出的牺牲。这一切每天都在发生。这些无声、无私的行为就在我们身边发生，而我们一无所知。
adults. It is just natural. I would call it parental behavior. To a degree that we would consider to be extreme. They turn out to be just awesome mothers. The act of inducing the young to come to her and start feeding on her is absolutely intentional. She is inviting them. She's asking them to do this, and this is her sacrifice for her youngsters. This happens every day. These quiet, selfless acts all around us and we have no idea.
我们制作《罪犯》已经超过三年了。当我们开始时，我们着手探索那些你可能意想不到的犯罪故事。所以，我们决定尝试一些新东西，一个像犯罪一样庞大、多变且可以说是过度曝光的主题。爱。
We've been making criminal for more than three years. And when we began, we set out to explore stories about crime that went places you might not have seen coming. And so, we thought we'd try our hand at something new, a subject as enormous and varied and arguably overexposed as crime. Love. criminal isn't going anywhere, but we're also going to bring you this new thing, a show about people, not spiders, dealing with the inescapable nature of love, and how a simple act of love isn't always pretty or grand and doesn't always make things better, but can change the course of it all. We're incredibly excited about these stories, and we hope you'll listen.
《罪犯》不会消失，但我们也将为你带来这个新节目——一个关于人而非蜘蛛的节目，探讨爱那不可逃避的本质，以及一个简单的爱的行为并不总是美丽或宏大的，它并不总能让事情变得更好，但却能改变一切的进程。我们对这些故事感到无比兴奋，希望你们会去听。
I'm Phoebe Judge, and this is Love. You can subscribe and Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts, and learn more at thisislovepodcast.com. 99% Invisible is Emmett Fitzgerald, who helped me edit this interview. Avery Truffman,-Sharifuse of Terran Mazza, composer Sean Rial, senior producer Katie Mingle, senior editor Delaney Hall, digital director Kurt Colstead, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting.
我是菲比·尤奇，这就是《爱》。你可以在苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方订阅，并在thisislovepodcast.com了解更多信息。《99%隐形》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，他协助我剪辑了这次采访。埃弗里·特鲁夫曼、谢里夫斯·奥夫·泰兰·马扎、作曲家肖恩·里亚尔、高级制作人凯蒂·明格、高级编辑德兰尼·霍尔、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德，还有我，罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街制作。我们是PRX旗下广播乌托邦（Radiotopia）的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。
We are supported by our listeners. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want to learn the difference between the rounded rectangle and the mathematically more complex but much more pleasing, squircle, you'll never look at app icons the same way again. It'll bug you forever.
我们由听众资助。你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我（@Roman Mars），也可以@节目（@99PI Org）。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但如果你想了解圆角矩形和数学上更复杂但看起来更悦目的“圆方角（squircle）”之间的区别，你将再也无法以同样的眼光看待应用图标了。这件事会永远折磨着你。
This is our gift to you. Go to 99PI.org. Radio TMP. From PRX. www.radiotapia.org Radio Tapia From PRX There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是我们送给你的礼物。访问 99PI.org。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。www.radiotopia.org。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。